des milliers de façons de mourir pendant
une guerre le gars qui a des côtés tu
dois avoir confiance en lui et lui doit
avoir confiance en toi
la delta c'est la meilleure compagnie du
bataillon une agence semi c'est aussi
dire qu'on dit sous mes ordres je
devrais avoir d'autres professionnels et
des tortues est mort et c'est mon ami
mais je me retrouve ici a biberonné une
bande de gosses à toutes les unités
notre artillerie à repousser l'ennemi et
maintenant par le chercher à langmann
ils ont tiré ils se sont barrés on va
rien trouvé là-bas espérons le mans
lieutenant et ses quatre buts on se fait
allumer
ça a l'air sérieux on va pas s'en sortir
tous les ennemis arrivent de tous les
côtés
il veut qu'on vit sa position si vous
bombardez pas dans les 30 secondes
on va tous crever on ne peut pas au trio
majeur et le commandant sur le champ de
bataille c'est à lui décidé donne
l'ordre
bah tu m'entends mon pote je voudrais
juste me tirer d'ici me marier
et oublier tout ça
comment peut on faire confiance
on a onze iem section cp et bleu vous
avez ordre de rentrer à la base entre
tous ensemble où personne ne rentre
toutes ses munitions dans les hélicos
qu'on va commencer à redescendre
rangement ouais je vous aime les mecs
soyez forts protéger les vôtres vous
êtes à compagnie delta
l'expert